en la última presentación espero haberte
dado un poco de intuición de lo que es
una derivada que realmente solo es una
forma de encontrar la pendiente en un
punto dado de una curva ahora vamos a
aplicarla a alguna función en particular
digamos que tengo la función f x igual a
x cuadrada muy bien entonces tengo yo
esta función y digamos que quiero
calcular la pendiente la pendiente en
algún punto en particular digamos x
igual a 3 muy bien entonces voy a hacer
rápidamente un dibujo de qué es lo que
quiero hacer digamos que aquí tengo a
mis ejes como siempre me falla a la hora
de trazar los
que llegamos ahí está el eje y y aquí
está el eje x muy bien y yo voy a
dibujar aquí la gráfica de x cuadrada
entonces son más o menos es una parábola
de esta forma muy bien ahí está
fx igual a equis cuadrada y me voy a
fijar en el punto x igual a 3 digamos
que este es x igual a 3 y el valor que
toma la función pues debería ser 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 yo sé que ésta no es
una escala verdadera pero más o menos se
entiende la idea muy bien entonces para
aplicar el límite yo necesito moverme
ligeramente a la derecha ok y digamos
esto es 3 + h y vemos qué pasa con la
función en 3 + h muy bien digamos que
aquí está la función aplicada a 3 + h y
esto será 3 + h al cuadrado verdad
simplemente este punto de aquí tiene
coordenadas 3 + h coma 3 + h al cuadrado
y este punto de aquí déjenme ponerlo con
el mismo color
tiene coordenadas 39 entonces sí quiero
aproximar la pendiente de la recta
tangente en este punto lo que voy a
tener que hacer es calcular la pendiente
pero de la recta secante muy bien
entonces como cálculo la pendiente de la
recta secante pues esencialmente es el
cambio entre el cambio en xy el cambio
en y lo podemos calcular como 3 + h al
cuadrado y le restamos la coordenada de
este punto de este primer punto y esto
lo dividimos entre el cambio en x que
simplemente es 3 + h - la equis de este
punto que es 3 menos 3 muy bien y esto
aquí será igual
esto si lo desarrollamos es 9 + 2 por 3
6 por h 6 h
+ h cuadrada verdad simplemente
desarrolle el binomio al cuadrado y
luego restamos 9 y todo esto va dividido
entre 3 + h menos 3
simplemente nos queda h muy bien
entonces acá arriba podemos simplificar
estos 9 se cancelan y esto me queda 6 h
más h cuadrada sobre h y que esto sí si
dividimos el numerador entre h tenemos 6
más
h muy bien y esta es la pendiente de la
recta secante ahora bien yo necesito
calcular el límite de esto cuando h
tiende a 0 para que se vaya esto
aproximando a 3 verdad que se aproxime
de esta forma entonces eso es algo muy
sencillo porque si yo quiero calcular el
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de 6 + h pues
simplemente 6 esto simplemente es 6
eso me está diciendo que si yo me fijo
en este punto y construyó la recta
tangente a la gráfica muy bien ahí está
la recta tangente en en x igual a 3 la
pendiente de esta recta es decir la
tangente de este ángulo va a ser igual a
6 muy bien entonces esto es bastante
útil si fx representar a por ejemplo la
posición de un cuerpo que se está
moviendo la derivada en su velocidad
instantánea pero ya tendremos tiempo
para hablar de eso y las aplicaciones en
física entonces vamos a ver qué pasa en
cualquier punto en general que digamos
en cualquier punto en general digamos
que tenemos
fx entonces igual a equis cuadrada y yo
voy a calcular el límite el límite
cuando h tiende a cero perdón cuando the
hatchet cuando es el límite cuando h
tiende a cero de fx más h
fx
sobre h muy bien esto es calcular la
pendiente de la recta secante muy bien y
al meter el límite cuando h tiende a
cero esto simplemente me da la pendiente
pero de la recta tangente y esto es sólo
para que te familiarices con la
anotación es f prima de x aunque esto
representa a la derivada de f en el
punto x donde x es cualquier punto en
particular entonces vamos a calcular
este límite esto es el límite cuando h
tiende a cero de fx + h pero fs x al
cuadrado así que tendremos x + h
esto al cuadrado y luego si aplicamos f
a x será simplemente x cuadrada y está
dividido entre h el numerador lo
desarrollamos y que nos queda x cuadrada
más 2 x h más h cuadrada y luego
restamos x cuadrada y dividimos entre h
bueno aquí aquí me faltó poner el límite
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de esto y no
tenemos que podemos simplificar este - x
cuadrada se va con este y lo que nos
queda es lo siguiente el límite límite
cuando h tiende a 0 b
2x h + h cuadrada sobre h y nuevamente
esto lo podemos simplificar verdad esto
es el límite cuando h tiende a 0 de que
si si dividimos el numerador entre h en
el primer término nos queda 2x y acá es
h cuadrado entre h es h muy bien y si
aplicamos el límite cuando h tiende a 0
esto simplemente será 2x y aquí ya
tenemos la derivada en cualquier punto
es decir la derivada en el punto x será
igual a 2 veces x así que si por ejemplo
tú tienes un punto en la gráfica por
ejemplo el punto 16 256 verdad esto está
en la gráfica de la función porque el
cuadrado de 16 es 256 entonces la
pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto simplemente será 2x que en este
caso es 2 por 16 que es 32
creo que esto es bastante genial y en un
futuro
y explicarte cómo aplicar esto en física
y problemas de optimización y un montón
de otras cosas muy divertidas y también
te mostraré cómo calcular la derivada de
muchas otras funciones por lo mientras
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo